You
Is that some better there's an echo
What about now
Why am I so bad at this
You hear that
You
Okay
Okay, no more. No, you don't get it easy. We are getting rid of the AC. No AC for you.
If you're European, no AC for you. What do you like the AC? Why do you like the AC?
Okay, fine. I'll put it back. Okay, here it goes.
Oh my god, that's too loud. Holy shit. Okay.
We'll have it like a little...
You guys aren't going to be able to hear the AC anyways because I'm going to put rain sounds on. So like, what the hell?
I'm mad at the people who are going to make me help before you. No. Congrats on quitting. You're such a badass, but honestly, I wouldn't be able to do it if it wasn't for you.
It's because of all the members that I'm able to do this. So I won't give credit where it's due. Yes, if you don't know, I quit my job.
I just smacked my mouth against the mic.
My ear, my hands, my background, and 9 o'clock Eastern time is when my phone goes off, so my ears are red.
I quit my job. It was actually very, very hard. I will probably cry tomorrow morning.
Because, um, I think I'm supposed to cry, but it's because I've been there for almost six years, and...
Oh, goodbye AC, but I've been there for almost six years. It was probably one of the best jobs I ever had until the company started making some changes.
It was time to move on. I had outgrown everything, and I tried, you know, applying for a part-time position and a different part of my store, but it was time, it was time.
I wasn't a manager, but I was a temporary assistant manager for quite some time.
And you see, good this time in the background. Nothing else has changed. I kind of still have a sense.
I hope you have a good time at leverage of what you do.
But I actually started, like, the ASMR, ASMR portion, because I have this whole role-play planned out.
I'm not going to be reading any tonos or supas. You currently can't see any stream elements, tonos, or, and I turned off the words just so you can really immerse yourself.
I want to do, like, a very serious role-play for you, a little bit silly, but mostly serious.
I'm not going to go off the rails like I did last time.
But yeah, we're ourselves in the picture.
Yes, I have so many triggers next to me. Actually, I have to go cook it some more, but I love the other room.
So, let me do that again. I'm sorry. Okay, I can't keep whispering. Let me just turn myself down for a second.
Okay, I'm going to document this a bit.
But, like, lower. So, yeah, it's really hard.
I can't really express how difficult it is, even though it's...
So, before I make this up, I'm going to read the tonos, don't know how many words, but don't miss the stuff on YouTube, so if you want to do that, okay?
Turn myself up again? Okay, sorry.
Yeah, I don't know how that works. I know...
I know some people don't care about it at all, and some people like it right at the end.
Yeah, yeah, it's... My parents are, like, very supportive. I'm obviously generally surprised. Sorry if I hear booby in the background.
But, you know, we'll look for another job.
Guess what?
Health and strength. He doesn't even know how. He just, like, moors. He just goes, like, whew whew whew.
He doesn't open his mouth. He doesn't meow. Yeah, he mows. Yeah, he does. He does a lot of that.
Bring up his staring daggers at him right now.
Okay, he's ignoring me.
Let me see if I can do something.
Like, yeah, I just wanted to, oh my fucking god, rena, what the fuck are you doing?
She just, she just jumped up on my desk and started sniffing the microphone.
Basically, you just get a lot of chatting stream and great past and current don't knows.
What really?
Maybe. Do you think you'd be good part of her?
Possibly.
I mean, I guess we could probably do something.
She slipped down. She was, like, a little suspicious.
Okay, so I'm gonna get rid of, like, some of the noise that's going on.
It's getting deep off. I think it's, like, my neighbor's voice is going off.
It just has a popping noise.
Whoa.
Can you hear that? I don't know if you can.
Huh? Okay.
Now I see for you.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I'm so sorry.
I know that this sounds the same on the 3D hotel.
But, um, bearing off like it went down is more, that's actually the good thing.
Louder.
This is literally my reason.
And then, like, the 3D picks up every little vibration.
Hortics.
And then I try to just always go, go, go.
And just, like, we're, I mean, I'm still sitting on my desk just staring at the 3D.
I'm gonna go over there.
But I, you know, I wanted to be able to, um, just rub a bit so I can help my abs out.
And I can check on you guys.
You can see where my head is at, you know.
Uh, she knows that you guys are with me, yes.
Um, cause I just, I might, like, cause like, what I was thinking.
I read the donos at the end in the soopas, but then I kinda like, cut it from the void.
I don't know if that's like, inappropriate.
Again, I know.
I'm not used to this.
So, please tell me what you think is best.
I am willing to take any advice you can take.
Um, hello everybody, just coming in.
Cause I don't have a special pass.
Yeah, can't we take on someone?
Again.
But, um, I'm kinda in a world of emotions right now.
So, it might be a little, um, next few days.
Could leave a little bit of thought and cut off the beginning of the next day.
Oh, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
I actually might do that as far as I can.
I accidentally did that the next day.
I like, come out, I just like tried to, I just like, saved it as a new video.
People were like laughing at me about it.
I was like, cool man.
God damn it, I fucked it up again.
Um, I might do that.
I might do that.
Good idea.
Um, that's my good idea.
But yeah, it's, um, I already had my job.
I like, mentored a lot of people.
I was like, a new manager for a band.
Um, I have amazing customers, amazing co-workers, um, on-state, amazing management.
I won't lie about that.
We have, like, a bet of minutes, but then, like, the values of the company kind of dramatically changed in this act.
Like, we're all so close.
Um, my store was super huge.
We had, like, over a hundred employees.
Um, and I can, like, 100% send me that.
Most people were by family.
Like, it sounds stupid, but, like, they were really awesome.
Um, and, and I started there when I was younger.
And then, I kind of, like, grew up in the store.
Like, I mean, I had a lot of experience.
Um, learning how to be, like, in the customer-based position.
And it was just, it was just really awesome.
Um, being someone to ask for a job site sale.
I'm in the hallway with four of my best friends.
I've had my own job, and all of them just left.
And a lot of them drained me.
And it was just kind of funny because now,
we've been following in our footsteps.
Um, got up out of by someone.
No, no, it's like, um, my company is humongous.
Uh, I'll say that much.
Um, my ex-company.
Um, it's all about what had happened.
It's just, like, you know, corporations, for instance.
You know how corporations are.
They just, uh, sometimes, yeah, they intersect.
They're corporations.
And they need to make profit.
Uh, sometimes, though, so there are values about their place
and their staff aside to kind of be like,
okay, how do we make more money?
You know, to sacrifice that, maybe,
don't drink the staff as well,
or maybe, like, you're in a hiring freeze for a long time.
I mean, you did hire people,
but it's just stressed us,
that we're going to put us in other places
just to want to be, that wasn't our only job, you know?
Like...
But yeah, it's, it is what it is, you know?
If this one dude just struggled to hear me,
I bet he might be broke,
because everybody else seems fine.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah, they hurt themselves a lot, right?
Like, a lot of people are leaving my company right now.
Um, and, like, I'm not the first person,
like, me and one person,
literally left the same day.
And then, I think,
and another person was telling me
they just put in their two weeks.
It was so...
It is what it is.
So...
I should probably come over here next minute.
Yeah.
Like, my reading, like, it wasn't normal reading.
Um...
They had a very...
Oh my god, I guess.
So much noise.
Why are you doing it?
Okay, there.
They're playing with toys.
Um, Raina is slowly sleeping on my desk now,
right next to my third deal.
Um, like, I don't want to take a picture.
She's sitting on my phone, never mind.
Oh, my phone is lost due to the warmth that is raining.
But they were all super happy,
and I was like, oh, I'm streaming full time,
because a lot of them, um,
oh my god, they...
stopped.
Um, a lot of them know that, um,
I'm a streamer.
It's uncompressed.
Um, they don't let me know what I am,
but, like, they're cool about it.
They're like, ah, I couldn't read it on the head.
It's so cool.
I would say, like, I know what made this person
not like my mom, me, duper on the Internet.
Nobody knows what a fucking me, duper is, bro.
You guys don't know the spell Raina or Boomi's name,
and then it's kind of funny.
Um, yeah, she's literally alone on my desk.
The first move is stream every day.
No, I'm kidding, um,
I'm probably gonna start me streaming
in my normal times after this week again.
Uh, like, 4 p.m. in the start time
and do, like, five days a week,
because I realize I need a time to relax
and I need a time to clean my house.
It's the same fucking mess.
I know, I know Raina,
Raina, the queen in Espanol,
but she is Raina,
and there's someone that I liked
a lot in, uh, America's Next Stop Model.
Hello.
Uh,
A
I
A, Raina.
And then Boomi is Boomi from Avatar,
Game of Omosha.
Um, he goes by Boompster.
Um, Metro Woman wants a more
game of word.
Um,
I don't know, he goes by, um,
oh no, he got an M, so sorry.
Um, he goes by Boomi, Boomerton.
He's still sp-spelled Raina Rock,
but it's okay, I love it best.
And then Fia is M-I-N.
Somebody thought of this full name
was Metro Boomin.
I'm like, you think I need my fucking cat,
Metro Boomin?
Who the fuck names her cat, Metro Boomin?
What?
Raina?
Is she fucking Australian?
Although, um, in their, like, veterinary files
like Fia is Fia the Deathbed Companion,
redacted, aka my last name,
and then Boomi is Boomi, King of Omoshu,
redacted, my last name.
So yeah, um,
I have allergies.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's the problem,
but then Raina's just a big mama.
Uh, she's also known as Jabba the Cat,
um, Queen of the, um,
Mamas.
But hey, Mamas.
I'm gonna pick up other things from her.
My dad calls her.
Yeah, Jabba the Cat.
Well, my dad calls her a wombat,
although he gets a wombat.
I've used some Happy Bar all the time,
so that's what it really means.
What is...
I'm trying to think what was going to say ever again.
Boomi, King of Omoshu, my last name.
Yeah, they're all wonderful kids,
and, um, Raina used to have a sister named Soleil,
before she passed away,
and she was, um, because of Raina,
so like, Raina and son, um,
yeah, I miss her, she's great.
But yeah, it actually reminds me a lot of her.
They have really similar personalities.
And then, before that, um,
all my other parents were named after
Bible characters,
because I remember I grew up
with a religious household, so, yeah.
I was like,
I don't remember it, like, church.
I was talking to
me and my, um,
like, my best friend at the time.
Mind you, we're like, fucking dead.
And we're like, am I good?
If we ever had a son, we, um,
like, us together, we're like,
if I ever had a son,
like, well, we'd name ourselves.
And I was, like, dead set
on naming my kid Artist Xease,
because the fucking badass name,
like, just called art for sure.
I'm like, oh, is it sure for Arthur?
No, bitch, it's sure for Artist Xease.
Kick Artist Xease.
Form of Fusula.
Uh, uh.
A-R-D-E-X-E-R-X-E-S.
Um, and then my friend was like,
I would just
call, call my kid Paul,
I'd like to go off this.
Not those are loud.
Jesus, I brought you some
uh, rickets and some murder.
Murder.
Oh, Judas.
Great fun.
I'd have a son so I could
be pulling your son from behind me.
Um, but then I decided
that if I ever got, like, a badass dog,
that was a boy dog,
I'd name my, um, Artist Xease,
or, like, some sort of just
crazy-ass name.
Um, and if I had a girl dog,
I'd want a great pair of these,
and I want to name her Ducky,
and she's gonna make you cute and fluffy,
and she's gonna guard
all my livestock at my farm.
I don't think Ducky's cute.
I should blow my nose.
Uh, mind your ears.
Name the kids after
altering characters to be super cool,
actually. Oh my god, I just kind of,
kind of burped before.
If I can name a me too,
don't worry, it will seem good.
Shut up.
My son. Oh, good.
Nobody cares about your penny,
is great.
Hate, hate, hate...
Now are you gonna see me play
Elderdream DLC? Again, I don't
have an Elderdream for BC,
I played it on PS5.
It's a comfort game of mine,
and I'm debating whether or not
I should embarrass myself by playing it
online, um, and streaming.
Just because.
Like, I'm not good at games,
Good at games, I like to take my time with them, so, you know.
I don't know, I don't want people to see me try hard.
Just watch Johnny play, she's hardly playing it this week,
I'm pretty sure, next week, you know.
I'm not like, I will play it from some, okay, maybe.
Cause I'm sorry, but I don't wanna play
another Crapstrap treasure lesson, like,
this sounds like a beat on stream,
cause the amp on black, bro, I was dying.
Starting to link the shot color.
I finally got my throat payouts,
so I was able to order my shot color.
So that should be it, at some point, I don't fucking know.
Cause throat payouts take more than two weeks.
I was the first person to have a shot color to my throat,
and I'm the last person to get it.
I think, I'm gonna move right now, cause she's,
well, she looks really comfy, but I need to,
oh, she fell asleep, I can't move her now.
I can't move this old lady.
I'm so cute, my god.
She's a dead out of dead love right now,
I'm not gonna lie.
Perfectly dug to no tail on sight.
Amazing form, dead out of dead love.
I'm also debating from switching from headphones
to, like, over the ear headphones to any ear headphones,
I'm realizing that headphones kind of hurt my ears.
I'm due at least to put my contacts in every time I stream.
Because my glasses, plus, just, I don't know,
do have a big head, maybe, I don't know,
maybe I got a big head, not a big head's brain.
I don't know, hope to one day eat.
Perfect.
That's the best, that's the best, that's the best.
Double-tie a five-head old bookie-gulu,
I mean, no, I won't, in my grip.
But in short, before I start streaming,
just know this is like a little role-playing new one,
I hope you like it.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
do put my jobs in.
Good to have done it.
I want to help you, all my, my, members,
strong, me, the girls, are so supportive,
and like, they're really my personal cheerleaders,
and I can't wait for them to, I don't know,
I don't know, I want some job,
but who doesn't help me on this, you know?
Like, they, when I'm like, move out, or change jobs,
or I hope they also get the opportunity,
no, I don't want to, so I'll bring anything,
because it is better to be free,
I love my job, it just changed, you know?
You got, you grow up, and you have to move on.
Of course, okay, tell me if this is too loud, okay?
Is that too loud?
Still, oh, I'm so sorry, okay, let me turn that down.
Okay, go, go, go, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry,
I'm sorry, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Okay, I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit more.
Okay, how's that, is that better?
Is that better?
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
I mean, this sounds so good.
It looks so good.
Okay, a lot, a lot, a lot.
A lot, you can break kisses,
because you're about to be insulted a little bit, so.
I need to be louder, is that true?
I wish, sometimes, okay, YouTube, can you please,
please put in channel points, so people can redeem,
you're too loud, you're too quiet, I can be loud, okay, fine.
Let me turn myself on.
How's, how's that, is that, hi, oh, you got the AC,
you got the rain, perfect, it's like the AC too,
overbearing, or, my game, I'm like 18, it's gonna be real,
it's gonna be real, okay.
Dan, Dan, Dan, that's Rob, okay, okay.
We're gonna just see what happens.
Rain covers the AC, okay, perfect,
so we got some white noise, I think the AC will be good,
because I know this rain is copyright free,
but maybe the AC will kind of like,
be like the AI, well, I'm like a glaze,
so I'll get this again, it's running out of talk to me,
it was like, girl, you're gonna demonetize,
left or right, you need, and so I've been putting,
I'm gonna wear your cover up from now on, I'm sorry,
can you copy me, people, copy right, rain, okay, yes,
I know, it is what he said, it's what is true,
people copy right, fucking everything,
even if it's just fucking all beyonds, all beyonds.
I'm scared, rain is gonna lean on my keyboard,
I think that's good, hi, I don't know if you heard her squeak,
oh my god, your breath smells me, look at that,
why were you scared about a thunder coming after you?
Oh, thunder, thunder, thunder, thundercats,
it's really pretty outside, I wish I could take a picture
and see if you guys would mind my location,
it's like, big sky, and dusky, it's really pretty,
It's like pink sky and dusky. It's really pretty.
I almost named... I was debating whether or not it would be a Jidaro because she also kind of spots for some reason.
She's like really light spots, but I can do that.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'll be ready to go get something.
Delicious.
I'll drink it warm on the heart.
Okay, one second.
Okay.
40 minutes of the appage. Let's go.
Sorry to put the phone right now.
Okay.
And we're starting.
Hmm.
So weird to find one of those things here.
I've never seen anything like this before.
What is this? Do you know what side of the rain?
It's looking a lot like this.
Can't tell what it is.
It looks like a piece of trash.
I'm pretty sure it is trash.
And I still can't place it.
I guess I'll have to do some closer inspection.
I don't know if I want to get close to it.
It looks like it smells bad.
I'm pretty sure it smells bad.
At least it brought my umbrella, so I won't get soaking wet.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh god.
It looks so much worse and I'm close with it.
I don't even know what that is.
What is that?
What?
I'm going to go over here.
Oh, yeah.
It does smell bad.
Gross.
No.
This has to be trash.
It looks like crap.
It smells like crap.
It does make sense that it's near a dumpster in this alley that I've had.
Okay.
But I just, I can't tell what it is.
Do I want to know what it is?
Okay.
Let me just...
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
Yeah.
No.
Wait.
Wait a second.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I like stuff I can't tell what it is.
Okay.
Let me make some notes.
Maybe it's like an animal or something.
Or a creature.
No.
A creature.
Okay.
No.
No, I think so.
Alright, let's see here.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Let me remember the pencil on some of them.
I can sketch, what if I, oh yeah, shade right there, I'll just wrinkle it, whatever, that's fine, that's fine
and now, yeah, now this, this piece of trash is way out of there, that's what I drew, we just sliced that
now we're done, now we're done, I've never seen something so disgusting, I sliced that
uh, now uh, it's like, it's like genuinely hideous, I can't stand to look at it, but like for science, I'll continue
okay, a couple of rounds
here
shade, okay
okay
whatever
shade, okay
okay, one of its, I don't know if that's one, it's, it's just dirty, nothing more
okay, wait a second, what do I think?
okay, there's like something here, I think I can scratch it off, maybe
let's try it out
good thing I always have my tools on me to look at weird things and have the face that look like shade
shade
this thing is kicked on, this is like mud or something like that
okay, it's just gonna take a little bit of time
okay, let's try it on
oh, oh, oh, okay
this thing, you may have purchased this thing, that's making it look like shade, but it's made me expect it, so it looks so good
it sounds kind of shiny
oh, oh, oh, that's disgusting, never mind, let's not do that
Okay, now we're getting somewhere.
It's a weird, choking substance.
It's a weird, trashy object.
It reminds me of something here.
I'm going to put it over here and just brush the victim.
Yeah, what if I do it slower?
If you think the stuff will melt away in the rain.
I think it doesn't have a mouth.
This thing was sitting in my mind.
Interesting.
My cats get out of here in the rain.
I'm crazy.
Gosh, this stuff is so cute.
You have to put it on.
I'm very, very curious.
Oh, right here.
This one.
This one's black.
Brush.
To bring it away.
Yeah.
Better areas over here.
How do you even know what you're doing with this stuff?
What if this piece of junk is completely useless?
Oh, no, that's my cat.
No, no, no, no.
Come on, pick it up.
Just toss it off.
That was a mess.
That's pretty good.
Oh, that was a big piece.
Almost there.
Barely done, so deep.
Just a little deeper.
Oh, this is really huge.
Do I got it?
Come on.
What is this?
This can't be trash.
Okay, papers.
Pretty trashy dust.
Interesting.
My color is green.
Is it brown?
Is it blue?
Okay, one second.
Looks a lot better than I did before.
And the hearing is very interesting.
Okay, one second.